زعيم المعارضه
امام هذا الحشد سوف يلقي اهلا بكم
[تصفيق]
هناك في
هذه لا نعيش هنا من اجل دفع الضرائب وان
نرسل لاولادنا الى الجيش
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاخوه الظلمه العارمه في الشهور
الاخيره
حدث شيء واحد هذا المعسكر الليبرالي
التقدمي الذي ينهض
[تصفيق]
هذا المعسكر
الذين تجاهلوه في السنوات الاخيره
يقوم الان من بين الاموات
احد ويا القيم التي نرفعها
ويدوس مبادئنا
الديمقراطيه لا تبني نفسها بنفسها
هذا المعسكر هو للمؤمنين بالديمقراطيه
نؤمن بالديمقراطيه ونؤمن ببنود وثيقه
الاستقلال ولا يوجد اي حكومه اعطتنا هذه
الحقوق ولن نسمح لها حكومه بان تسلبنا
حقوقنا
ولم نسكت ولم نستعيد
حتى تكون لاسرائيل دستور حتى يكون
لاسرائيل دستور
[تصفيق]
لن نسكت حتى يكون لاسرائيل دستور
اقوال زعيم المعارضه
نحن هنا
في دوله حره وديمقراطيه يجب ان نناضل من
اجل ذلك واذا اردنا ان نوقف الانقلاب على
النظام الحكومه علينا ان نخرج الى الشارع
من اجل ان نحارب على مستقبلنا ومستقبل
اولادنا هنالك امر واحد ان المتطرفين في
هذه الحكومه لم ياخذوه بعين الاعتبار انتم
انتم
قواتكم هذه
وحقيره الحقيقه التي ترفعونها
هم اعتقدوا انهم سوف يبلبلونكم
باذكر وحدث
العكس تماما
مئه الاف الاسرائيلي اسرائيل في كل مفترق
في كل بلده ما حدث في شوارع اسرائيل في
الشهور الاخيره سوف يسجل في التاريخ
بانه المظاهره الاكبر في
الارض
هؤلاء الذين اليوم ويتظاهرون في كل انحاء
اسرائيل
قاموا بعمل سح ساحر
المفاعل في ديمونا وسلاح الجو
الثقافه والمصرع وانظر الى كل هؤلاء
وعشرات
الاعلام هذه التي ترفع التي يحملها
الوطنيون الاسرائيليون الذين لا يؤمنون به
حقوق
بحقوق المراه وبحقوق العرب
والفصل بين السلطات وحريه
التعبير وحريه الاحتجاج وحريه الدين وفي
استقلاليه المحاكم والقضاء في اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اي مشكله
معا مع مع الناس الذين يختلفون عننا لكن
اذا ارادوا ان نعيش هنا معا عليهم ان
يحترموا قيمنا ما هو مقدس لنا ليس اقل
قدسيه مما يعتقدون به
[تصفيق]
وفي الايام القريبه القادمه
ربما في الشهور القادمه نحن سوف
نحاول لا يخدعوننا
يقوم احد بخداعنا سوف نكون متاكدين من ذلك
وسنضمن ذلك
لن نسمح لاحد بخداعنا يقول زعيم المعارضه
لا وزير الدفاع
لم يقل وزير الدفاع هو اقال الواقع
والحقيقه
[تصفيق]
الشعب يهطف الخزي والعار لهذه الحكومه
اصوات المحتجين يقولون الخزي والعار لقد
اقال الحقيقه لان الحقيقه انه فيها الشهور
الثلاثه من الفوضى
لقد قامت بهدم واباده
هذه الدوله
هذه هذا
التغييرات القانونيه
تزعزع استقرار الاقتصاد في اسرائيل
تمزق المجتمع الاسرائيلي لاشلاء هذه
التشريعات يجب ان تتوقف ويجب ان نعود الى
الحياه المشتركه